-Our next guest is a talented
actor you know from films
like "The Hunger Games,"
"Logan Lucky," and "Scream."
He stars in the hit
Amazon series "The Boys."
New episodes stream Fridays
on Prime Video.
Let's take a look.
-But I promised no more secrets,
right?
So --
-Oh, my God.
Hughie.
-Hold on. One second.
-You found more V.
-It's temporary V.
It's temporary, okay?
I'm not an idiot.
I -- I know it's sketchy.
I've seen "Trainspotting."
But it's Soldier Boy.
I mean, what else
was I supposed to do?
-Please welcome to the show,
Jack Quaid, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hey!
-Hey! Welcome to the show, Jack!
I'm so happy to have you here.
-So good to be here.
Thank you so much for having me.
-You're from LA.
You live there now, but you've
spent a lot of time in New York.
-I did. I went to college here.
I went to NYU.
And as surreal as it is
to be here with you right now,
it's even more surreal to see
people like Henry Melcher
and Matt Reitman backstage.
-These are members of our staff,
who we,
over the course of the day,
have been showing photos of
you guys in college together.
-Yeah, yeah. Just doing comedy,
having acne, being dorks.
It's been great, yeah.
-You were living it up.
You were ticking off
all the wish list.
-The prime of my life.
-Yeah.
-Yes. Truly.
-Now "The Boys"
is a very dark show,
but it's also a very funny show.
-Yes.
-And I think those two
synthesized very well when
you were nominated for an Emmy,
but in the category
of Best Drama.
-Yes, we were nominated --
We are a show
in which people blow up.
There's a lot of nudity.
There's a lot of blood.
-Yep.
-And, yeah, we were
nominated for Best Drama.
And I think the way
that it happened was so funny.
Like, you know,
there's that clip that they show
where they
actually nominate you.
And it was a very serious man,
and he basically went,
"And now the final category,
Best Drama."
And then it shows a clip of us,
and it's me screaming
in a speedboat
as we drive a speedboat into
the stomach of a beached whale.
-Yeah.
-So that was the clip.
And then they immediately cut
to "Bridgerton,"
which was just, like,
very serious period drama.
And I was like, "This is, mwah.
This is chef's kiss."
-It really does,
I feel like, tell you --
let's just watch, because it
is exactly how you describe it.
-I love this clip so much.
-Outstanding Drama Series.
Here are the nominees.
[ Men screaming ]
-"The Boys."
[ Screaming, boat revving ]
[ Squelch ]
[ Whale shrieks ]
-"Bridgerton."
[ Laughter ]
-Now, it did cut away,
because the "Bridgerton" clip
also had a whale in it.
-Oh, right.
-That was that famous
"Bridgerton" scene.
-It was a whale-heavy year.
A whale-heavy year.
-They always say,
that was the whale year.
-That was the whale year.
Definitely.
-We saw from the clip,
your character, Hughie,
did not originally
have superpowers.
-No, no, yeah.
-And now you have the power
of teleportation,
and I feel like
one of the nice things about
the honest portrayal of
superheroes in "The Boys,"
is that you accept the fact
about teleportation
that a lot of
superhero shows would ignore.
-Exactly, yeah.
So, you know,
if you're teleporting, it's your
biological mass or whatever.
I'm no scientist,
but it's your biological mass
going from one part of the room
to another,
so your clothes naturally
wouldn't come with you.
So in our show,
whenever Hughie teleports,
his clothes
stay where he started,
and then I emerge
on the other side, naked.
So I had a lot of nudity
this season.
Yeah.
-This is very exciting.
This is what they offer you?
-Yeah, so this
is called modesty wear.
And it may be worse
than being actually naked.
So when you're shooting
the scene,
you're not actually naked.
You're wearing one of these
things.
[ Audience groans ]
-And if you're wondering
how it goes on,
they provide you with this.
[ Laughter ]
-It's like an at-home
COVID test, you know?
They have, like,
the instructions,
and I think the worst one --
-How do you think...?
Yeah, what do you think you do?
-That's the worst.
-Oh, so this is like --
this is like, not -- yeah.
I get it now.
What did you choose?
-I don't know how
into detail I can get,
but I did not choose that one.
-So obviously, I mean,
the instructions
are too complicated.
-Yeah, no.
It's too highbrow for me.
For sure, definitely.
-You were also
in the "Scream" film
that came out.
-Yes.
-That must've been
a fun project to be in.
And I feel like, I will say,
I feel like enough time
has passed
to say that you had
a very interesting role.
-I did. And this is very weird
for me to say out loud.
And audience,
please cover your ears
if you don't want "Scream"
spoiled for you.
But I was the killer.
-Congratulations.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers ]
-I mean, that's a big get.
-That's a funny thing to
congratulate a person for.
"You murdered!
Good for you."
-But the killer, to be
the killer in "Scream."
I mean, if you're
going to be a killer.
-Yeah, it was awesome.
They told me initially,
and then I immediately
didn't believe them,
because what they do when
they shoot a "Scream" movie is
they want to prevent leaks,
so they gave the entire cast
fake scripts
with different victims,
different killers,
different everything.
So they told me
I was the killer.
I was like, "Okay."
And then we were shooting
in North Carolina and I had to,
like, keep this secret
from the rest of the cast
that I was the killer.
But then I thought --
-That's -- A lot of killers
have to do that.
-Yes, they do.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I was really in character.
Also on top of that,
we were playing Mafia a lot
when we were, like,
in our downtime.
So we were playing a whodunit
while shooting a whodunit.
It was very meta.
But, yeah, it was really weird.
-Do you think there was some
intra-cast jealousy
when they found out
you were the actual killer?
-I don't know.
I don't know if that's, like,
a thing you get jealous about,
necessarily,
but it was crazy,
because at one point,
I thought, "Wait a minute.
They said I'm the killer.
Maybe they're lying to me."
-Right.
-Maybe they're pulling, like,
a crazy other twist
and I'm gonna wind up,
like, dead in an alleyway
and not be a killer at all.
And that would have been,
I guess, bad?
I don't know, yeah.
-Well, I can't believe
I'm saying it,
but congrats
on being the killer.
-Thanks.
I guess I prefer to murder.
That's great.
-Well, I'm glad.
You know, we try to dig in
on this show
and get to the bottom
of who our guests are,
and I'm glad we found that out
about you.
-I am a serial killer.
[ Laughter ]
Hello, America.
[ Applause ]
-Hey, man, congrats again
on the show.
It's so special and so unique,
and you're so wonderful on it.
Thank you for being here.
You guys, Jack Quaid.
New episodes of "The Boys"
stream Fridays on Prime Video.
We'll be right back
with Sandy Honig,
Mitra Jouhari,
and Alyssa Stonoha.